au quatrième étage de cette résidence
une serre de 800 mètres carrés un
aménagement peu banal à l'intérieur deux
mille cinq cents plants de légumes en
pleine croissance
aucune trace de terre ici on cultive en
hydroponie les drapeaux ni c'est un
système de culture qui consiste à
cultiver des plantes dans un support
tiello vous sortir une plante pour bien
voir ça on voit bien que la plante ou
totalement dans une gouttière rempli
d'eau donc ça m'a sera signalé très
importante
une technique qui permet un rendement
optimal et une démarche biologique dans
quelques jours la première production
arrivera à maturité et ce sont les
habitants de la résidence qui en auront
la primeur plus tard ses légumes seront
proposées au grand public sur internet
et dans des points relais
l'expérience unique en son genre en
touraine a nécessité une technologie de
construction toute particulière encadré
par un bailleur social et un lycée
horticole et agricoles
ce projet il a mis un petit peu de temps
parce que en termes de construction
c'est pas aussi évident que ça vous
imaginez en ordre une certes au
quatrième étage
il faut prévoir et concevoir le bâtiment
pour ça il n'est pas possible de mettre
des serres sur des bâtiments existants
tout a été conçu pour permettre de créer
cet essai en coiffure un outil qui crée
du lien social puisque les habitants de
la résidence peuvent participer à des
ateliers tout comme les élèves de
l'agrocampus qui en profite pour des
stages et des formations